[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
during the
confirmation hearings for judge amy
coney barrett soon
to be justice amy coney barrett
democratic senator dianne feinstein was
caught on a hot mic
saying that she knew for barrett this
issue of abortion
it was a very personal it was a
religious issue for her
now i think dianne feinstein doesn't
want to admit that abortion
is a personal and religious issue for
people on the left
as well i mean they've made it
essentially into a sacrament now
and here to help us understand this
abortion issue
as it exists today in modern america we
have
danielle d'souza gill danielle is the
author of the choice
the abortion divide in america you have
seen danielle
all over television you've seen her in
lots of political capacities
and now she is going to help us
understand how abortion has changed
in the public discourse danielle thank
you for being here
hi michael thank you so much for having
me i'm
so pleased to have you because there's
been this huge shift and i think
the amy coney barrett hearings have
embodied this have have exemplified this
we used to hear from democrats that
abortion was a very sad thing
something that i would never support but
i still think it should be politically
uh acceptable and legal it should be
safe legal and rare that's what we heard
in the mid-2000s from hillary clinton
now it seems
that people want to shout it from the
rooftops there there's nothing wrong
with abortion i mean the safe legal rare
thing never made a lot of sense
because if it's not wrong then why does
it have to be rare
and if it is wrong why should it be
legal but so they never they were trying
to
split the baby if you will to use an apt
metaphor
what changed what has empowered the left
now to so embrace
abortion well yeah i think as you
mentioned this safe
legal and rare uh you know doctrine that
they were putting forth in 1973
all up until the 2000s was kind of
intended to
say open the floodgates to abortion i
think they knew that
people inside kind of knew it was wrong
they knew it was something bad but they
had to say you know what we're going to
keep it very limited
because that's a way we can kind of
crack a deal with you guys as the
american people in order to get this out
there
but as we've seen them today the
democrats today celebrate nine month
abortions
governor cuomo in new york lit up the
freedom tower pink to celebrate
nine month abortions for no medical
reason i've seen
ralph northam talk about you know
keeping the baby comfortable after it's
born and then a discussion ensuing as to
what would happen to it next
so when we really go into it there there
isn't too much middle ground on it
either this is a human life and this is
a person
or this is quote a cluster of cells an
appendix a body part as they like to say
not worthy of protection so i think that
people are actually realizing that
that whole middle ground ideology as you
were saying safely and rare
doesn't actually make any sense because
we're talking about either life or death
when it comes to this human being
you know right now we're about 50 50 in
the country on
people who support abortion and people
who oppose it which is better than we
were in past decades there have been
times when
when people were much more in favor of
abortion but we seem to have deadlocked
around 50
50. is this just one of those issues
that we're not going to resolve that
we're basically
going to be in a stalemate forever or is
there some hope that we're going to
convince
people to stop allowing the legal
killing of babies
yeah i don't think so i think it's a
little more nuanced i think the polls
have shown
that over 75 percent of americans are
against late term abortion
they're against federal funding for
abortion and so i think that we could
actually come to a place where most
americans could agree
maybe on a heartbeat bill or some other
kind of limitation
and then we could discuss okay maybe we
should make our discussions more
surrounding something like that
but in any case most americans look at a
baby at nine months and say wow you know
this really is a full-fledged human this
is a full-fledged baby
in order to kill this child it's going
to be a very big effort
so i think that there's um um actually a
lot of support for that for as far as
most americans who are not even
necessarily pro-life
um from the moment of conception i'd be
curious to hear because i know you like
to steal man you know
the other people's arguments here what
do you think is the strongest argument
for abortion what's the best argument
that they have at their disposal
well i would say most pro-lifers would
probably agree that when they bring up
kind of the hard cases maybe cases of
rape cases of incest things like that
i would say those are um especially
heartbreaking because
uh you know all of us are against that
of having ever occurred in the first
place but
i think that um the main thing to keep
in mind is the fact that all of those
hard case exceptions mean when we look
at incest it's less than 0.01
of the time rape is usually less than
one percent of the time so
we're talking about very rare instances
and the left of course doesn't say
hey we're gonna go going to be against
abortion in all other cases
except for this no you know if you had
said okay you know not
not not in that situation they would
still be for abortion but even if we
zoom in on that i think what's most
disturbing
is the fact that people on the left
advocate for the death penalty for the
child and not for the rapist
and of course the child had absolutely
nothing to do with that action but
they actually want you know lighter
crime sentences and you know they're
against things like that for rapists
serial killers so i think in order to
stop that we have to stop you know the
rape from occurring in the first place
sure it's a great point you bring up
that they they're
crying about the death penalty for all
sorts of awful killers and rapists
and yet when we're talking about the
death penalty with no due process
for little babies they're perfectly fine
with that
this issue of the hard cases too you
bring up it
it accounts for so few abortions every
year and yet
we always hear from the left when we
bring up their support of abortion in
in the ninth month in the third
trimester if you're
in the case of the virginia governor
ralph northam he suggested we have
fourth trimester abortions he suggested
the baby could be born and you could
still kill it and what they say to
conservatives is
oh gosh come off it there are so few
abortions that happen
in those cases maybe that's true but
then how come they keep making
making their arguments in the extreme
all the way
on the other end in what accounts for
less than one percent
of abortions yeah well actually i think
too that that is a little bit of a
misnomer that they're putting out there
because planned parenthood has been
increasing their clinics that perform
late-term abortions
and we've increased them um i think up
about 30
more clinics in the last few years so
what does that tell us it shows that
there is
increasing demand for late term
abortions or maybe they are pushing late
term abortion more in their rhetoric
and you know their abortion finder you
can find on their website things like
that
so they're not trying to distance
themselves from late-term abortion and
say okay how can we stop this they're
actually pushing late term abortion
so when they try to then come at us by
saying oh why do you bring up late term
abortion
well this is why we bring it up you know
you wouldn't be lighting up the freedom
tower ping for late term abortion if
that wasn't something that was actually
very near and dear to your heart to push
that's an excellent point i'm reminded
of naomi
wolfe naomi wolfe is the this
accidentally honest feminist
maybe not maybe she intends to be honest
some of the time but she she gave an
argument for abortion that i felt
was totally consistent and ghastly she
said
more or less that men and women are
different
men can't get pregnant women can get
pregnant
sex will have more serious consequences
for women
than it will for men and the only way to
have true equality
is to permit women to kill their
children that's the only way that men
and women are going to be
anywhere near equal because of these
biological differences
you're a woman you seem very empowered
you seem
perfectly uh you know in command of
yourself i don't think you're under a
false consciousness
where do these left-wing radical
arguments go wrong are we just saying
that
women can't be equal to men yeah i do
write about naomi wolf in my book
because i do think her arguments are so
interesting just in the sense that
feminists on the left really do
kind of try to marry abortion and
empowerment to make it seem like you
have to have an abortion in order to be
successful you have to have an abortion
in order to be happy
you have to have an abortion in order to
kind of live the modern lifestyle
all of this and so i think that actually
she called out a little bit of the fact
that
maybe this requires mourning um you know
this is a human life here
but still said you know we should still
proceed with abortion and i think that's
kind of
interesting because a lot of feminists
on the other side want to say no
no this isn't a life no this isn't a
person but i think that when you look at
modern science and you look at how
technology's developed with the
ultrasound hearing the heartbeat
there's no way to say this isn't a human
so the left then has to pivot and say
this is a human
but it's not a person in order to kind
of dehumanize that person and say okay
now this gives us the right
to take its life because we are sort of
defining it in this very special
definition i i always find their
discussion of
personhood to be just the really lame
liberal version of talking about a soul
because that's what they're talking
about right i mean
i i you you remain a if you're a human
being you're a person
there's no distinction here they're
trying to make this distinction without
a difference and what they're really
talking about
used to be in christian conversation
the question of when does the soul enter
the human body
and so do you find that the
the way in which the left is discussing
this matter
relies primarily on say science or
relies primarily on
political ideology or do you think that
it goes a little further to
paraphrase dianne feinstein into a loud
dogma living within them i definitely
think the left's ideology is
far departed from science because they
do not acknowledge even things like the
heartbeat or
you know the fact that the baby releases
cortisol the same stress responses that
we release when we're under
duress when we're in pain they do not
anesthetize infants that are aborted
you know in the late trimester so they
go through a lot of suffering and pain
in that process it's not an immediate
death
so no i think they're they're far off
from science and their ideology really
is based on almost kind of a religious
conviction
and a dedication to abortion and i think
even when we look at their rhetoric
this whole idea that um you know it's
it's my body
my choice they're just so adamant about
it almost in the sense that you would
see them as like religious fanatics when
many people actually on our side are
very nice and very kind and very willing
to discuss the issue with them
uh whenever i've gone to the march for
life there are people you know who are
very peaceful and willing to talk but
that's not what the women's march looks
like you know the the late columnist
charles krauthammer
referred to the left having taken up the
sacramental view of abortion
and abortion was no longer this uh
unfortunate thing that happens
but now it's it's actually this high
sacrament and leftism and the
philosopher peter craft makes a great
point
that i i think you just touch on which
is that
abortion becomes this inverse
blasphemous sacrament uh you know in
christianity you have the eucharist you
have the communion host which is the
body of christ
and then in leftism you have this
abortion that uses the same
exact words this is my body
albeit in peter's words to blasphemously
opposite ends so when we're trying to
refute
the arguments for abortion where do you
think we should begin
do we begin with the sort of scientific
argument and say look it's obviously
alive and he's obviously
a baby do you move on to a political
argument and say
women have perfect equality under the
law but they have you know biological
differences and so
that's not an excuse to kill their
babies or do you make a religious
argument over
what a human being is why we have
dignity in the first place
how how we should relate to the laws
where where do you think is the most
persuasive way in
well i think we win on all of those
things i think we went on every issue i
think
it's true when it comes to the spiritual
component when it comes to the
scientific
component i think the human rights
aspect of it is really interesting
looking at the fact
that you know this is really the
greatest human rights violation of our
time and
and these are human beings um but i'm
glad that you mentioned that about kind
of this inversion
of the religious aspect and i think
something that's so interesting to me
when i think
you know about the birth of jesus and
just the fact that that really was
the first unplanned pregnancy not in the
eyes of god but in the eyes of you know
mary and joseph
and i think also thinking about the fact
that they uplift not only the child but
also
the mother mary and i think that is how
we view
um you know we as pro-lifers view it we
not only value the child but also the
mother
and um looking today even to just how
the abortion movement has really just
uh warped all of this their
organizations like shout your abortion
god loves abortion they um self-foam
fingers pointing to the
to the sky saying you know god loves
abortion post photos of babies
uh wearing halos and and with with
shirts that say god loves abortion
things like that
and it's just very sickening to see kind
of the narrative that the left is
pushing which is that
this is actually something that is um
you know
on god's side and even when joe biden
and kamal harris use words like faith
after mike pence um and the debates
mentioned you know being
unapologetically pro-life she then
pivots to saying well
you know joe biden is catholic and we're
people of faith and it's like
that's not a shield to hide behind to
justify your pro-abortion stance to
justify your stance on
federal funding for abortion joe biden
is also a heretic who was rightly denied
the eucharist at a mass so i i think his
his espousing is is is using his faith
as a shield against
these kind of criticisms is very very
disgusting
but they do it anyway they they do this
all the time pelosi does this you know i
don't know i guess she
went to church a few times in her life
or something like that
but i i i find this to be a kind of
a dismissal you know when that when they
say well it's just your religious view
they they attempt to dismiss it that way
but of course
you know there was a time when we could
have religious debates when we get a
philosophical debates
not as though they were just a matter of
personal preference but as though they
were getting at some kind of truth and
that has been totally pushed to the side
i'm even seeing in the amy coney barrett
hearings you you see this
bizarre use of the phrase handmade they
keep
they keep referring to her as the
handmaid's tale that stupid margaret
atwood book that none of them have even
read they've probably just watched the
tv show
and they don't realize that the term
handmade here is referring to
the virgin mary who says i am the
handmaid of the lord at the annunciation
and then you have you have the
incarnation of christ that has been
turned in leftism
that to be a handmaid is the worst thing
of all to give birth it's the worst
thing of all
i i say this all because it seems to me
the culture is so
far gone we have lost so many premises
in our culture
do we even have the abortion debate on
the question of abortion itself
or do we have to fix the broader culture
first to be able to fix the abortion
question
well i think the abortion question
really illuminates
this problem that you're talking about
this deeper problem this bigger
spiritual problem and kind of
a lack of desire for truth that anyone
seems to really have anymore
but i think that deep down people
actually have a deep hunger for this and
they're not being given it
and i think when we look even at the amy
coney barrett hearings
we see that you know um they're willing
to throw
throw faith in her face and kind of use
it against her when they want to but
then when we look at joe biden and kamal
harris they want to use it to their
advantage when they want to
so it's not actually about the faith
itself it's not actually about truth or
about beliefs
it's just about you know when can we
score a political point and so i think
that most americans see this and think
you know
actually this actually means something
to me whether you're a person of faith
or not
we should probably take this seriously
whether you accept it or reject it
and i think that actually the abortion
issue can really bring to the forefront
um deeper moral questions and deeper um
you know interest in just what is the
right to life
where do our rights come from does it
come from the government
or does it come from our creator or some
kind of intrinsic human right
and um i think when we see the the
babies that that are lost every year and
just the grand
scale that this mass killing is
happening i just don't see how we can
continue to ignore it when this issue
has just been bubbling to the forefront
of politics
for so long well this is an issue
actually that we haven't really touched
on which is
sure you've got the politics sure you've
got the science sure you've got the
religion
but what about just a simple matter of
law we have now been told for almost
50 years that there is a constitutional
right
to abortion and i've looked over that
document i have a magnifying glass
i look really closely in blue light and
i can't find
the text of the right to an abortion
anywhere in the constitution but our
judges tell us
it exists where does that come from yeah
you know i love the fact that marsha
blackburn
brought that up she said in the hearing
she said abortion is nowhere to be
mentioned in the constitution
and amy coney barrett also said that roe
v wade is not super precedent
why because it hasn't been accepted by
the american people
so i think this idea that roe v wade is
somehow completely set in stone and we
can't overturn it i mean everyone knows
this
is ridiculous and the left wouldn't be
in such apoplexy and have so much fear
about this
if they actually thought it was set in
stone i think they know it's overturning
is coming
and it's really just a matter of time
and even joe biden has talked about the
fact that
when roe v wade is overturned they
basically plan to put the same
um the same language into the
legislation
so they want to you know replicate it
not from the supreme court but to put it
into law
so that basically they can continue
doing the same thing and you know
maybe certain states will do that but
that doesn't mean that we shouldn't
overturn roe v
wade we absolutely should and i think
it's just a matter of time
i certainly hope it's a matter of time
because something about this abortion
issue
it only strikes me every i don't know
every few months or something
which is that we can look at stalin's
purges and we say oh my gosh it was the
worst thing
ever how could you imagine anybody doing
that sort of thing you look at
hitler you look at mao you look at
milosevic i don't know you look at all
these
sort of awful terrible political leaders
and you say oh my gosh those atrocities
could you imagine that
luckily where are the good guys though
luckily we're on the good side in a good
country
we kill a million babies per year in
this country
we've killed over 60 million babies
legally
since roe vs wade half of the country
cheers that on
what will historians say about us
you know i think this reminds me a lot
of the issue of slavery
i think that in the time of slavery um
you know they were of course living in a
different time and people now look back
and say wow
i can't believe that so many people
participated in this i can't believe so
many people
you know remained silent and didn't
speak out against it and the
abolitionists were such a small faction
you know many of them were christians
but a lot of christians were not
abolitionists
and yet later many in history look back
and kind of want to take moral credit
and say oh you know
i would have been against slavery i
would have been on that side and i think
that's how people will look at it with
the
with the abortion issue later people
look back and say why did more people
not speak up why did more people not get
involved
and it's like you know later they are
going to want to take moral credit but
it's like where were you when we needed
you where were you when we were actually
in the fight
of our lives and um unfortunately we
live in this
in this age where people want to virtue
signal and take credit when it's cool
when it's popular but when
the issue is actually at stake and in
the forefront many people don't want to
take up the cause and that's what i hope
we can change
absolutely right i think people also if
they want to speak up will need to be
able to articulate the arguments against
abortion
one great way to do that which i would
recommend is go
out and get the book the choice the
abortion divide in america
by the lovely danielle d'souza gill
danielle where else can people find you
you can find me
on uh you know twitter probably censored
um instagram facebook parlor i'm
danielle de souza gill on all the
platforms and the book is the choice
the abortion divide in america you know
we're on all those platforms now
certainly we're going to get kicked off
and then the place you'll find us is
screaming from the street corner
somewhere
until the authorities pull us away but
until then you can find us online
danielle
thank you so much for being here thank
you so much for having me
[Music]
[Music]